[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport c'est parti pour le sommaire de
ce magazine rugby en fédérale 2 plaisir
s'est imposé ce week-end contre
gennevillois 2006 lingu feder pour le
plaisir ou au classement les joueurs de
sébastien roncalli s'éloigne de la zone
de relégation les détails dans ce set 8
sport automobile evans aspen les nerfs
des jeunes pilotes français à suivre à
16 ans est imminente 1me participe à la
porsche carrera cup cette année nous le
recevrons dans quelques instants
cyclisme la sélection piste pour les
championnats du monde de berlin a été
dévoilée la semaine dernière on
retrouvera notamment des pistards du
vélo-club elancourt saint quentin en
yvelines comme quentin lafargue
plus d'informations à suivre l'actualité
sportive de la semaine c'est maintenant
sur tv 78
[Musique]
on commence donc par du rugby dans le
championnat de fédérale 2 plaisir
s'offrent une bouffée d'oxygène les
hommes de sébastien roncalli ont battu
gennevillois ce week-end un adversaire
direct pour le maintien le résumé du
match des images de manon à varaldo avis
de tempête sur plaisir ce dimanche 16
février l'équipe locale en difficulté en
fédérale 2 recevait sous les bourrasques
de vent un autre prétendant la descente
gennevillois après avoir concédé
l'ouverture du score les plaisirs hoa
réagissent et reviennent dans le match
avec deux pénalités et un essai le score
à la pause 11 à 7
la première période on a choisi de jouer
avec le vent maintenant c'était pas
c'était pas forcément au final un autre
avantage parce que le score est pas si
significatif que ça à la mi temps et on
avait choisi de jouer avec le vent pour
pour justement prendre un avantage un
peu plus important en deuxième période
plaisir accentue son avance malgré
quelques frayeurs en fin de match une
bagarre générale plaisir l'emportent sur
le score de 18 à 12 mon sentiment c'est
que c'était le plus beau match de la
saison après les conditions c'est sûr
faisait que ça rend les choses un peu
plus compliqué beaucoup de vent mais bon
sang on est quand même bien sorti
et ça donne une grosse bouffée d'oxygène
pour la suite
saison donc ça fait du bien une bouffée
d'oxygène qui se traduit au classement
plaisir dernier il ya quelques semaines
remonte à la 9e place avec deux points
d'avancé sur son adversaire du jour
c'est la première fois de l'année qu'on
enchaîne de bons résultats 2 victoires
donc voilà j'espère que la dynamique va
pas s'arrêter à ces deux matches et puis
qu'on va pouvoir continuer à engranger
des points et on a un peu de confiance
quoi maintenant
j'ai un groupe qui est ambitieux j'ai
des joueurs qui sont ambitieux donc on
ira jusqu où on pourra aller avec grand
plaisir pour continuer sa série de
victoires plaisir se déplacera sur le
terrain de beauvais ce dimanche 23
février le deuxième de la poule on joue
est également un étage plus bas en
fédérale 3 versailles continue sa belle
série et joueurs de la cité royale se
sont imposés 20 à 15 sur le terrain de
vincennes ce week-end résultat qui
permet au versailles et de conserver la
troisième place du championnat ils ne
sont plus qu'à cinq points de la
deuxième place détenue par gretz tournan
prochain match contre eux à domicile un
match de handball maintenant nationale 2
féminine montigny le bretonneux s'est
inclinée ce week-end à l'extérieur chez
saint grégoire rennes métropole
score final 24 à 22 malgré les neuf buts
de kristen delgado des gr k malgré à
cette défaite montigny le bretonneux
reste tout de même troisième du
classement prochain match le 29 février
à domicile contre hull on va maintenant
ouvrir une page sport automobile il a
tout juste 16 ans et rêve de conduire un
jour une formule 1 mais avant cela il va
participer cette année à la porsche
carrera cup france c'est un plaisir de
recevoir evanna spenlé sur ce plateau
bonsoir on ça alors avant de parler de
vos ambitions pour cette année 2020 on
va revenir sur votre passion pour le
sport automobile
vous avez commencé à 8 ans on se
remettront pas ouais j'ai commencé à 8
ans donc sur une école de karting à
paris donc on y aller toutes les deux
semaines avec mon père et puis et puis
un jour il m'a lancé il m'a dit est ce
que tu veux un quartier et on commence
la compétition et j'ai dit oui c'était
un déclic ça a été un déclic j'ai tout
de suite tout de suite adoré le fait
d'être entouré de bonnes personnes de
deux roulés contre des autres en fait
l'esprit compétition
j'adorais tout de suite et puis voilà
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on atteint le
sport auto est ce que vous vous souvenez
de votre première victoire
première victoire c'était je ne sais
plus et et mai
je m'en souviens comme si c'était hier
oui c'était c'est quelque chose de
différent les podiums à côté c'est
deuxième place 3e place et quelque chose
mais une victoire ça s'oublie pas c'est
la victoire quoi qu'il arrive pour la
victoire quoi qu'il arrive alors en 2017
vous avez terminé troisième du
championnat d'europe est 11e du
championnat du monde ce lien c'est ça
donc on est rejeté dans une la catégorie
qui s'appelle x 30 juniors
j'habite en angleterre avec mes parents
donc on roulait en assure le seul sur le
championnat anglais
et puis on faisait à côté de ça le
championnat d'europe et j'ai participé
au championnat du monde aussi
je termine troisième donc comme vous
l'avez dit du championnat d'europe est
11e du mondial alors est ce qu'un pilote
vous a donné envie de faire du sport
automobile
bien sûr un pilote comme bas les pilotes
les anciens pilotes comme schumacher
ayrton senna ex et ça ça donne envie
c'est des gens qui sont qui sont déjà
très fort mentalement
il montre il montre tout tout l'univers
du sport auto ex et a donc oui ça donne
envie et puis ça m'inspirait qu'est ce
qui vous plaît dans leur conduite
la conduite peu d'auteurs agressive la
conduite agressive c'était des tous deux
des personnes très très compétiteur avec
mon p tit i et voilà c'est quelque chose
qui m'a toujours attiré alors je
rappelle que vous n'avez pas encore le
permis vous avez 16 ans mais vous roule
à combien exactement
l'année dernière donc en formule quatre
championnats de france de formule 4g
atteint une vitesse de pointe de 220 km
à à peu près sur circuit de spa
francorchamps donc sur une grande ligne
droite et tout cela sans permis alors en
2019 vous avez piloté lors des
championnats de france f4 et fia est-ce
que c'est déjà une belle étape dans la
progression de vos carrières oui c'est
déjà de passer du kart à la monoplace
c'est quelque chose de d'assez
conséquent assez compliqué à apprendre
parce que c'est pas le même pilotage il
faut adapter son pilotage etc
c'est une voiture un kart c'est tout
petit est passé sur une voiture c'est
complètement complètement différent donc
on va prend tout de da partir de zéro
qu'est ce qui change
justement ce qui change les pneus les
pneus la puissance
le comportement de la voiture il ya
notamment le transfert de charges qui
éprouvent beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
élevés beaucoup plus fort et puis voilà
l'info comme je le dis il faut tout
réadapter comment vous entraînez
quotidiennement quotidiennement on
s'entraîne donc sur un peu tous les
circuits de france ou d'europe
donc voilà on a des journées test prévu
pour le dans l'année et sinon je
m'entraîne physiquement à côté de ça
parce que c'est un sport assez physique
donc je m'entraîne physiquement au cheo
intégré au pôle espoir france au pôle
france à pau moment la fédération
française de sport automobile donc on
est suivi on a un suivi sportif un suivi
psychologique etc alors voulu participer
à la porsche carrera cup pourquoi
pourquoi parce que c'est porsche porsche
c'est quelque chose que tout le monde
tout le monde connaisse etc des voitures
là donc j'étais en monoplace l'année
dernière là on passa de là j'étais
complètement un univers complètement
différent là la voiture n'est pas la
même donc donc voilà ça change
complètement et c'est porsche c'est une
grosse famille et donc voilà très
content de pouvoir participer à ce
championnat
quel est le niveau justement d'une
porsche carrera cup le niveau d'une
porsche carrera cup c'est donc déjà
c'est un championnat complètement
européen en fait on à dire des européens
qui qui viennent sur le championnat de
france pour rouler il intègre en fait
ils font venir le championnat de
belgique de temps en temps ou
championnat d'allemagne sur nos sur le
haut nos meetings
donc voilà il ya ça monte jusqu'à 60
voitures sur le sur la même piste
donc c'est très très élevé alors dans le
calendrier il y aura barcelone ce
parlement monza mais les cours et paul
ricard mais le plus gros événement on va
pas se le cacher c'est des 24 heures du
mans selma devant 350 mille personnes
c'est ça donc on a la chance de pouvoir
faire les l'ouverture des 24 heures du
mans cette année donc voilà très très
content et très très très impatient d'y
aller
votre voiture sera une porsche 911 gt3
c'est sa gt3 cup
alors est ce que c'est une voiture
compétitive c'est une voiture
compétitive on a deux sens
285 chevaux sous le moteur on atteint
des pointes de 260 km/heure donc
donc ouais c'est très très puissant pour
pour mon âge à 16 ans et demi donc est
ce que c'est un palier pour aller vers
les grosses compétitions internationales
comme la f1 ou des compétitions ce type
là f1 bas la f1 c'est c'est comme jeudi
à notre univers c'est la monoplace donc
aujourd'hui
moi j'ai opté pour la gt donc je vais
rester dans cet univers et évoluer petit
à petit en gt mais donc voilà on à la
chambre donc en porsche cup france et
ensuite le niveau d'eau dessus c'est la
super cup donc tous ceux qui sont avant
les meetings de formule 1 et donc voilà
c'est mon but
mon but c'est d'y arriver alors pour
participer à toutes ses courses vous
avez besoin de financement combien ça
coûte est ce que ça coûte cher c'est ça
besoins de financement c'est très
compliqué ça toujours été cher c'est le
sport auto tout le monde le sait
aujourd'hui une saison de porsche
carrera cup s'élève à 250 milles euros
donc donc je recherche justement des
partenariats donc sa part de 500 euros
puisque 500 euros si ces cinq cent mille
500 + 500 ça peut arriver à une grosse
somme donc donc on parle de 500 euros en
contact des entreprises et puis on
attend et on cherche du comment on fait
pour vous aider justement comment on
fait pour m'aider ont donc sur les
réseaux voilages et evans peiné sur
instagram twitter facebook etc
vous pouvez me contacter et c'est c'est
tout simple écrits furent là merci à
vous d'être passé sur ce plateau vous
souhaite beaucoup de réussite dans votre
carrière et surtout beaucoup de
victoires si vous remercie beaucoup
direction maintenant le vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines en
cyclisme la liste des sportifs retenus
en équipe de france pour les
championnats du monde sur piste à berlin
fin février a été dévoilée ce mercredi à
dans l'enceinte des images de patrick
jacques de dixmude une conférence de
presse attendue la sélection piste pour
les championnats du monde de berlin
était dévoilée ce rendez vous organisé
du 26 février au 1er mars fera office de
test à quelques mois des jeux olympiques
on a une équipe de france qui
très bien dans sa trajectoire par
rapport à tokyo et du coup qui va
aborder ces championnats du monde à la
fois pour y faire des résultats pour
performer est ce que c'est important est
à la fois également je pense pour
prendre de l'assurance de la confiance
là où il ya besoin dans la construction
vers tokyo sur les épreuves d'endurance
on retrouvera notamment à certains bryan
coquard champion du monde en 2015 sur la
piste du vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
je me sens plutôt bien à vrai dire j'ai
créé repris l'entraînement veut dire le
1er décembre
et voilà ces derniers entraînements sur
piste sont plutôt plutôt encourageant je
participerai à la course au championnat
du monde
je suis champion d'europe en titre bien
évidemment genre j ai envie de bien
faire du côté du sprint pas de surprise
on retrouve les désormais
incontournables grégory baugé sébastien
vigion ou encore mathilde de gros mais
l'une des stars de cette équipe de
france sera quentin lafargue les blinois
licencié au vc le sky avait remporté
l'or sur le kilomètre et large en
vitesse par équipes sur les derniers
mondiaux en 2019
c'est toujours un moment important cette
sélection est et ce championnat du monde
tous les ans qui revient mais qui fait
toujours plaisir afin de porter porté
les couleurs des équipes de france bat
au plus haut niveau donc je l'attendais
je l'espérais et je suis content de
faire partie du collectif la fédération
française n'a pas voulu annoncer
d'objectif chiffré de médailles sur les
championnats du monde les premières
épreuves sont programmées le mercredi 26
février à partir de 13 heures vous
l'avez vu dans leurs reportages
précédents quentin lafargue sera l'une
des têtes d'affiché françaises de cette
équipe de france 2020 et viennois
licencié au vc e sky avait notamment
remporté l'or sur le kilomètre sur les
derniers mondiaux en 2019 des
performances qu'ils comptent rééditer
nous avons pu le rencontrer
nous sommes au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines et la
sélection piste pour les championnats du
monde de cyclisme sur piste vient de
tomber
quant à la fargue du bseo sky et dans
l'équipe quentin lafargue
ce n'est pas une surprise de vous voir
dans cette équipe non malgré tout c'est
toujours un moment important cette
sélection et et
ce championnat du monde tous les ans qui
revient mais qui fait toujours plaisir à
afin de porter porté les couleurs des
équipes de france au plus haut niveau
donc je l'attendais je l'espérais et je
suis content de faire partie du
collectif
vous allez participer à quelques
épreuves je vais participer à la vitesse
par équipes en tant que post 3 3e tour
et au kilomètre sur lequel du coup jour
j'ai deux médailles à défendre puisque
la vitesse par équipes on était vice
champion du monde l'année dernière et
sur le kilomètre j'ai été champion du
monde en 2019 donc donc de médailles à
défendre et une changer de métal si
possible justement vous êtes plus à
l'aise sur le kilomètre ou sur la
vitesse dans la vitesse par équipes
c'est là l'épreuve qui va me permettre
d'accéder à la suite de la saison tout
le monde en parle beaucoup après les
championnats du monde y aura les jeux
olympiques de tokyo donc donc l'objectif
c'est d'être très performant à berlin
pour justement justifier ma place dans
l'équipe de france olympique est même
sélectionné pour les jeux olympiques de
tokyo et par ordre chronologique donc il
y aura d'abord la vitesse par équipes et
ensuite le kilomètre donc sont deux
épreuves que j'affectionne énormément
et l'objectif sera d'être le plus
performant possible sur le rappel pour
les téléspectateurs le kilomètre n'est
pas au programme des jeux olympiques est
ce que c'est une petite déception parce
que forcément c'était une chance de
médaille pour vous ben non ça l'est pas
parce que parce que on l'a pas appris
hier on sait déjà depuis quelques halls
1 fiad
malgré tout c'est une discipline qui
fait partie du programme des
championnats du monde c'est un maillot
que j'ai beaucoup aimé porter tout au
long de l'année donc il ya encore un
maillot de champion du monde à gagner
dans cette épreuve là
donc voilà me donnera pas accès au jeu
ça c'est clair et net par contre ma mes
qualités
les qualités que j'arrive à exploiter
sur l'épreuve du kilomètre sont assez
similaires à celles qui sont nécessaires
à celle du troisième tour en vitesse par
équipes donc je je
fondent beaucoup d'ambitions non dans
l'épreuve de la vitesse par équipes
aussi et et ma préparation pour le
kilomètre me servirai nommément pour la
vitesse par équipes ces championnats du
monde se dérouleront à berlin à partir
du 26 février est ce que c'est une piste
vous connaissez bien et si oui quelles
sont ses spécificités
oui c'est puisqu'on connaît bien on y
aller on y est allés plusieurs fois ces
dernières années et j'ai de bons
souvenirs là bas puisque on a été
champions d'europe de vitesse par équipe
justement en 2010 est de bonne augure du
coup donc voilà c'est une piste que
j'affectionne bien ses proches de la
france aussi donc les gens les nos
supporters vont pouvoir se déplacer se
déplacer aussi et ça c'est ça c'est ça
c'est top
et en termes de spécificités on est sur
une piste qui est particulière puisque
on n'a pas du tout accès à la lumière du
jour
à la différence de ce qu'on peut
connaître ici à saint quentin là c'est
une piste qui est plutôt d'enfin dans un
espace très fermé et qui voit là en
terme de dessin est différente de la
piste d'ici de saint quentin mais mais
qui qui n'est pas problématique pour moi
et sur laquelle je saurai m'adapter
rapidement
plus globalement qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette équipe de france de
piste est ce qu'elle est belle pour
remporter des médailles
oui en tous les cas elle et elle a été
elle est déterminée à aller chercher le
plus de médailles possibles on a été
tous très sérieux dans notre préparation
que ce soit à l'entraînement ou en
dehors de l'entraînement aussi un une
performance à se construit pas que que
en faisant des tours de pédales sur la
piste donc voila moi j'ai beaucoup de
confiance en ce collectif est une chose
est sûre on vit tous bien ensemble et et
notre ambition qui parfois peut être
individuelle sert toujours à un autre
collectif
on est dans un an bénéficie d'une
épreuve par équipe sur laquelle en à
chacun des rôles très très individuelle
donc il est très important pour nous
tous bah de d'élever notre niveau à
titre individuel au service de ce
collectif là et là j'ai la conviction
que bas que tout le monde est dans cette
démarche là et ça c'est très positif
cette année il ya deux grosses échéances
les championnats du monde et les jeux
olympiques de tokyo
est ce qu'on peut avoir deux pics de
forme la même année voit de demander
demandez à un cycliste sur route si
c'est pas possible je pense que je pense
que des double vainqueurs de tours ou
autre d'ailleurs seront enfin serait
surpris quand vous dise non mais du coup
il bien sûr qu'il est possible d'avoir
deux gros pic de forme dans l'année
surtout qu'il ya quasi six mois de
différence entre les deux est d'écart
entre les deux compétitions donc il est
très important d'après moi d'avoir ces
deux pics de forme et d'avoir un
deuxième encore peut-être un peu plus
élevée dans la question les jeux
olympiques j'imagine que vous y pensez
quasiment tous les jours on est en année
olympique
les jo de tokyo au mois d'août on y
pense oui on y pense mais on est très
focalisée désole un sur les championnats
du monde de berlin qui arrive parce que
parce que mine de rien ben en pensant à
tokyo on se dit aussi que ben l'impasse
sur la route avant et que c'est une
étape obligatoire validé
sinon il y aura pas de suite en fait
donc d'abord berlin j'ai tendance à
prendre la saison étape par étape et
validé ces étapes avant de avant de nous
focaliser sur autre chose là j'ai besoin
d'être psychologiquement et mentalement
focaliser est complètement déterminé sur
l'objectif qui arrive qui est le
championnat du monde et ensuite on verra
mais à la question vous faites partie du
wc u sky saint quentin en yvelines
forcément vous voulez porter le club le
plus haut possible avec des médailles
oui bien sûr depuis l'année dernière
déjà avec quentin caleyron qui qui cette
année encore fait partie aussi du
collectif france et ben du coup on a je
suis très heureux aussi de me dire que
cette année on aura deux de licenciés du
vc sky de plus présent aux championnats
du monde puisque melvin landerneau qui
est
qui a signé récemment chez nous est
aussi sélectionné dans le collectif
print et les filles clara copponi qui
courent elles sur sur route pour la fdj
mais qui est licencié dans le club aussi
depuis cette année sera au départ des
championnats du monde donc une très
belle réussite une fierté un tout petit
peu personnel aussi dans le sens où j'ai
réussi à convaincre à convaincre ses
athlètes l'a22 nous rejoindre dans ce
beau projet et
et ça confirme que ce projet ce projet
tient la route aussi et que et quand on
est en droit de missionner encore plus
dans les années à venir
aujourd'hui 4 4 athlètes du vc au sky
seront au départ des championnats du
monde je pense que ça c'est c'est déjà
une belle réussite
merci quentin lafargue les championnats
du monde de cyclisme sur piste ce sera à
berlin à partir du 26 février des
résultats basket maintenant nationale 2
féminine le chesnay versailles s'est
incliné contre le leader escaudain le
fcv 78 n'a pas réussi à marquer plus de
44 points score final 60 à 44 au
classement les yvelinoises promu cette
saison redescendre à la troisième place
du classement chez les garçons ont joué
sur les parquets de nationale 3
masculine 0 sur 3 pour les équipes
chinoises marly-le-roi 5,77 à 50 face à
montville où peuvent ils
même sanction pour le chesnay versailles
qui perd 96 à 80 sur le terrain de rouen
enfin trap a été dominée par saint
thomas basket au classement les
trappistes sont toujours troisièmes et
le fcv 78 quatrième rallye droit est
toujours un bon dernier en football en
nationale 3 verset n'a pu faire mieux
que match nul à 0 à 0 contre les murs ou
lors de la 16e journée
ce résultat permet au versailles et de
conserver la première place mais les
joueurs de la cité royale voir revenir
le club d'ivry à deux petits points
verser recevra boulogne billancourt lors
de la prochaine journée fia je vous
propose maintenant de découvrir un sport
insolite vous en avez désormais à
l'habitude des journalistes de tv 78
viennent régulièrement sur ce plateau
pour nous présenter une discipline
originale aujourd'hui mélanie peau qui
nous a rejoint sur ce set sports bonsoir
ça alors mélanique qu avez-vous testé un
sport né et développé en france c'est la
savate forme une discipline qui allie le
ludique et la technique pour la
fédération française de savate les
pratiquants de cette discipline
représentent environ 7% de leurs
licenciés je vous propose de regarder de
la boxe sans affrontement un peu de
fitness et un mix qui donne la savate
forme et c'est le spark a décidé de
tester
78 et pour l'occasion une sommes
accueillis par l'école de boxe française
savate de l'enfant et de maurepas
[Applaudissements]
bon
allez comme bonjour bonjour vous allez
être mon coach aujourd'hui mais déjà
qu'est ce que la savate forme alors la
savate forme c'est une discipline de la
fédération de boxe française de savate
boxe française et donc l'idée c'est de
mettre les techniques de savate boxe
française en musique et en mode fitness
avec la possibilité aussi lorsqu'on
souhaite d'ajouter aussi et l'autre
discipline au sein de faire un cercle de
sava de défendre l'idée c'est de
feuilles fitness défait les cardiologues
fatigué en musique est ensemble et en
chorégraphies et dans un autre esprit
pratique et les mouvements de la base ça
s'adresse inquiet en tunisie sens
intitulé oui non oui oui c'est un peu
lui très très restreint c'est tout ce
qu'ils veulent voilà donc en général on
a quand même beaucoup beaucoup de filles
parce que c'est les filles
majoritairement le public féminin qui
est attiré par tout ce qui est fait
n'est ce et musique
[Musique]
c'est convivial par contre c'est
cérébrale quand même faut bien réfléchir
et tout et puis voilà on se dépense ou
s'amusent et puis c'est une bonne
ambiance
j'ai fait d'autres sports à côté que
j'ai abandonné finalement j'aurais
savate forme parce que ce familial je
trouve ça cool c'est vraiment un sport
complet qui nous correspond moi j'aime
bien parce que ça travaille beaucoup de
cardio et ça permet aussi de quand on
n'ose pas faire de la boxe quoi c'est
une introduction un corps qui débute
comme toute activité par un échauffement
[Musique]
les exercices peuvent véritablement
commencé endurance et souffle sont
donnés et le mot clé ces deux comtés
on
[Musique]
on en est à une heure de cours comment
je suis déjà bien essoufflé après un
show qu on démarre femme très très vite
j'ai peur de la suite finalement la
suite reste dans le rythme un peu de
cha-cha-cha comme l'appelle alexandre un
travail à deux en face à face
un bon moyen de travailler la
coordination et les réflexes
si vous aussi vous voulez pratiquer la
samba tant de rendez vous sont proposés
par le club
moi je vais les métiers h
[Musique]
alors mélanie avez vous réussi à
contenir
michael vous l'a vu sur les images j'ai
fini par y arriver alors le plus dur
pour moi vraiment ça a été de me défaire
de mes réflexes qui lie à la pratique de
la danse car dans cette discipline
on compte mais on n'a pas toujours les
mêmes départ de jean mais l'accueil
d'alexandre et des pratiquantes a
vraiment été très agréable moi je pense
que je me relis sept ans t'es bon on
m'avait donné envie d'essayer en tout
cas merci à vous mais la nuit on passe
maintenant notre page agenda
[Musique]
il y aura du rugby à ce week-end avec le
championnat honneur l'union rugby centre
60,18 se déplacera sur le terrain de vie
au grand air de saint maur les deux
équipes sont au coude à coude en milieu
de classement la rencontre aura lieu ce
dimanche à 15 heures au stade paul meyer
de sucy en brie
il y aura également du football avec le
championnat de régionale 2 un derby
nouveau programme où il recevra trappe
ce dimanche à 15 heures au stade maurice
baquet l'encontre très importante pour
les deux équipes qui visent le maintien
cette année seulement deux petits points
séparent pour l'instant les deux équipes
en cas de victoire trappe sortirait de
la zone rouge
les passionnés à de football américain
peuvent noter ce rendez-vous dans leur
agenda les templiers d'elancourt
reçoivent ce samedi soir les dockers de
nantes pour une rencontre qui sent la
poudre
les élans courtois veulent absolument
l'emporter dans cette rencontre pour
poursuivre leur série de deux victoires
et nantais sont eux en grande difficulté
avec zéro victoire en trois matches la
rencontre est programmée au complexe
sportif europe
on vous en parle depuis plusieurs
semaines la fiche officielle vient de
sortir le vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines va accueillir pour
la première fois de son histoire un
match de volleyball une rencontre de
première division
le clasico paris tours étaient
programmés dans la structure le 28 mars
prochain 19h sur le plan sportif tour et
promet du championnat paris 11e la
billetterie vient tout juste d'ouvrir la
rencontre sera suivie à part un concert
une dernière information sport avant de
se quitter et plus précisément de golf
il l'avait il avait illuminé la ryder
cup 2018 au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'anglais
tommy fleetwood et francesco molinari et
l'italien avait remporté tous leurs
matches en duo un 4 sur 4 légendaire une
véritable histoire d'amour sportive est
né pendant cette compétition les équipes
de la ryder cup europe
on en profite et en profiter de la colle
occasion de la saint-valentin
vendredi dernier pour ressortir une
ancienne vidéo humoristique du duo
baptisé bollywood
regardez
oh
32 ça fait un 5 sur 5 par francesco
molinari a gagné tous ses matches dont
son duel avec phil mickelson fleet food
avait lui perdu contre tony à finhaut
c'est déjà la fin de cette émission
merci d'avoir suivi très belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]